♪ Ils ont dansé dans le ciel ♪
♪ Ils en ont parlé
aux nouvelles ♪
♪ Un voyageur... ♪
- Patrice Michaud est fier
de son quatrième album,
sorti juste à temps pour
la reprise des spectacles.
PATRICE MICHAUD,
auteur-compositeur-interprète
- De toute façon, ça aurait
été un coup d'épée dans l'eau
de sortir un disque dans
les derniers mois.
Moi, vu la nature de l'artiste
que je suis, moi, j'ai arrivé
sur la scène avant d'arriver sur
disque. Fait que c'est pour...
J'ai hâte d'aller défendre
ces chansons-là en spectacle.
♪ ♪ ♪
- La rentrée musicale
est historique à cause
de son abondance. Ça se bouscule
au portillon chez les musiciens.
Car un disque est une carte
de visite pour vendre un billet
de concert. Ajoutez à cela que,
pour Nicola Ciconne, la pandémie
aura été source d'inspiration.
♪ Je nous imagine ♪
♪ Comblés et heureux ♪
NICOLA CICCONE,
auteur-compositeur-interprète
- Je trouve ça positif.
Puis en plus, c'est logique
parce que les artistes
créent quand ça va moins bien.
Ils créent quand ils se sentent
impuissants. Je pense
que, face à la pandémie,
les questionnements étaient
multiples. Fait que c'est
juste normal qu'il y ait
beaucoup d'artistes qui créent.
♪ On fait c'qu'on peut
avec quoi qu'la mer amène ♪
♪ À essayer d'gagner sa vie
aux Iles-de-la-Madeleine ♪
- Pour le groupe Salebarbes
et comme tant d'autres,
le confinement aura, en effet,
été un moteur de création.
Jorane a réalisé un album
grandiose.
♪ ♪ ♪
JORANE,
autrice-compositrice-interprète
- On m'a toujours dit
que la rentrée, c'était toujours
très chargé. Mais là, c'est
encore plus que d'habitude,
mais c'est normal. En fait, on a
tous été dans nos cocons en même
temps. Alors, tous les papillons
sortent en même temps.
♪ Comment savoir
si coeur qui bat ♪
- Face à ce foisonnement,
le choix sera déchirant
tant pour le public que
pour les chroniqueurs.
EUGÉNIE LÉPINE-BLONDEAU
chroniqueuse culturelle
- Il y a des beaux albums
qui vont probablement tomber
dans des craques, effectivement.
Il y a un tri qui doit se faire.
Comme chroniqueuse culturelle,
oui, je trouve qu'il y en a
beaucoup. J'ose pas dire qu'il
y en a trop parce qu'il y aura
toujours... Je suis persuadée
qu'il y aura toujours un public
pour le matériel qui sort.
♪ Quand mes yeux se fondent
au vert des tiens ♪
- Les mélomanes devront
donc faire leurs recherches
pour trouver l'album qui est
musique à leurs oreilles.
Ici Louis-Philippe Ouimet,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.